sans lui bonsoir alors ce qui est au
coeur des violences des derniers jours
des dernières semaines c'est vraiment
cette question très sensible des lieux
saints dans la vieille ville de
jérusalem
oui nous connaissons tous et images
schelin les deux mosquées qui se trouve
là bas c'est à dire la mosquée d'al aqsa
et le dôme du rocher se trouvent sur ce
qu'on appelle l'esplanade des mosquées
est en bas le lieu de culte des juifs le
mur des lamentations
quand l'armée israélienne c'est un pari
de ces lieux 5967 ça a créé un choc
spirituel dans le monde juif parce que
ça semblait réaliser une prophétie qui
disait né juif reviendrons et
reconstruirons là où se trouve
l'esplanade des mosquées reconstruirons
le temple du roi salomon le tente le des
temps bibliques mais le général qui
commandait l'armée israélienne à
l'époque moshe dayan a dit on ne peut
pas désacralisé comme ça des lieux
saints de l'islam
les juifs ne peuvent pas aller prier en
eau sur l'esplanade ils vont prier au
mur des lamentations
ça a été endossé à l'époque par le grand
rabbinat d'israël
et depuis c'est le statu quo et c'est la
peur aujourd'hui de voir ce statu quo là
se briser parce qu'il ya des
revendications des nationalistes
religieux juifs qui disent allons prier
sur l'esplanade des mosquées et il ya
même un projet de loi qui étaient
déposés à la knesset pour proposer qu'on
change ce statu quo et c'est ça qui a
enflammé les esprits
est ce que c'est cette société are you
love pourrait se réaliser parce que il
ya eu la police a dû intervenir
bactérien sondage industriel très récent
qui dit
56% des sites rennais veulent qu'on
maintienne le statu quo par contre il ya
une très forte forte hier si on veut qui
dit changeons des choses même au prix de
violence nous devons avoir le droit
d'aller prier là si cette opinion
continue à prendre de l'ampleur comme
c'était le cas ces dernières années
ça peut devenir très dangereux alors est
ce qu'on est en train de tomber dans une
guerre de religion ce n'était pas que ça
fait le caveau faut faire attention
parce que oui à des éléments religieux
mais il faut pas oublier qu'à l'origine
le conflit israélo palestinien c'est
d'abord un conflit territorial entre
deux nations c'est aussi un conflit
interracial interethniques savez il ya
des palestiniens minoritaire en israël
ils ont manifesté récemment parce qu'un
policier avait abattu un des leurs ils
sont pas descendus dans les rues en
criant avant les infidèles ils ont
dénoncé une situation
discriminatoire à leur yeux et non pas
religieuses ceci dit oui il ya une
augmentation de la préoccupation
religieuse dans ce conflit
et ça pourrait compliquer encore plus la
solution du problème à long terme et
personne ne sait où s'arrêtera cette
violence merci beaucoup lui qu ils ont
pris céline